what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
trailer for Netflix is mine hunter
season two loved season 1 love serial
killer love serial killers generally
speaking when I saw this guy play
Charles Manson I was like so excited
Seymour Manson in the show my hunter hey
we haven't mentioned this tune oh wow we
got a patreon page yeah image of the
table of leaves over there we do equally
q and A's there's several shows that we
do TV show reactions stream alongs for
and those are Cobra Kai season 2
haunting of Hill House season 1 Gotham
all the stranger things season 3 John
just started up agents of shield and
there are several shows where we do the
stream belongs and actually have
10-minute reaction highlights included
it's right footage as if this was a
YouTube video but you know restrictions
guidelines whatever and those are attack
on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood my hero academia we even
cover the movie as well Death Note just
started that up Code Geass just started
that one up as well one punch man hunter
x hunter and super natural we've made
the patreon page just easy to navigate
as possible thank you to everyone who's
pledged recently we had a really
successful month last month so thank you
guys hopefully more of you guys hop on
board the patronage our train January
1974 they've just moved in two months
prior first time saying he was feeling
for a life and something bumped him
that's when we found the little girl
hanging from this bike I found someone
to take over it'll be very good to be s
here he wants to expand the unit
[Music]
another missing sending thoughts off you
there for the duration so all these have
to be statistically rare for serial
killers to cross racial lines
there's also statistically significant
with the Klan kills blows this gun what
we think is another and zeros Klan
[Music]
we've got 19 dead black children you
telling me that's a coincidence
one more thing six days after my
sister's birthday now that's a bonding
experience for the ages you got to get
together you know celebrate venture
stuff I'm supposed to be babysitting
that weekend I know what I'm showing
that kid over a binge watch I'm gonna
psychoanalyze you and see what makes you
tick your little mind hunter why do you
sound like the perfect you know just
trying to subvert expectations because
it's what modern entertainments all
about me I'll give you Giggy a little
mine under no I'm just trying to make
this as creepy as I could as quickly as
possible first off when you go off
season one you have ad Kemp yeah thanks
ed and Ed O'Neill Garth Kemp Kemper yeah
there you go and then you had the setup
that they were wrapping around with the
BK killer the BTK killer yeah
no no very Burger King the Burger King
burger of the King how scary it would be
if the serial killer donned that king
mask see you never know they take
creative liberties with these shows then
this hype of Charles Manson's gonna be
in the show it's gonna be your house
it's like a hyper [ __ ] Street what I
would love so dearly as if he only shows
up once upon a time in Hollywood said
just one scene he walks through and
that's it that's been like the hype
because a halt has been one in the GAT
Manson for an interview man he's the
granddaddy of this trailer - he's a
friggin marble-like he's gonna come in
like some kind of big moment at the end
of like a cliffhanger at the end of the
first episode or something away Matt's
been treated in the media and it's weird
and once upon a time a Hollywood coming
out he has become like exactly this this
is like film character
of sorts you know and that extends
beyond like the horrible real-life
person he was [ __ ] strange seems like
the season is primarily focused on this
idea of there's like nineteen black
people who were murdered they think the
class responsible Holt believes that
there's a serial killer who's
responsible or it's kind of hard to take
up on him like David Fincher kind of
trailer yeah thoughts dots chaos it's
gonna build element of the different
stuff in the season but mostly what
you're feeling is just oh my god this is
so intensive I don't like psychological
headspace is you don't have enough room
to process anything and I mean you
pushed over the edge which is very
Fincher assets to show my special makes
really calm entertaining yeah it's very
meditative experiences that he makes
home home with all the things that have
been the most gravitating in terms of
the the hooks that you've been having I
don't know what the true story is behind
any of this behind people yeah I don't
know what who like if this is the exact
events of how the journey went down have
been very fictionalized or what it has
I always like with these kinds of things
now I always assume that the broad
strokes and and some of the themes are
mirroring real life in some way but
they're taken liberties to make this
entertainment yes if anything I'll take
these inspiration to read more ed
Kemper's it seems to have been this
character and this show that people
really like people really like it is
you're like real-life bad terrible
things like god-awful things they love
how good that actor yes like people eyes
are really just like the character or
they they hate how much they like that
character you know and that's how that
wondering if there's gonna be the same
effect of when they finally do get
Manson in here I'm wondering what the
overall wrap around is gonna be with
this series because this show originally
got compared to the likes of something
as like true detective course I like the
detectives and the obsession with
hunting down a serial killer yeah that
makes sense
philosophical and psychological it sure
detective has a like one story per
season yeah they wrap it up the last
season doesn't yeah and it's been a long
time since season with like at least in
my eyes it feels like it's been a long
few
year and a half like two years some in a
while I'm wondering where this is going
because I had the whole thing with the
BTK killer and you're like is that how
season 1 is gonna end yeah the BTK
killer get caught wait yes are they
still gonna have that be sort of a wrap
around here that would be is this is
gonna be one of those series that
ultimately ends with a time jump to
catch in the BT this one just seems like
right yeah whenever they get the axe
from Netflix they'll just you know make
that the last three yeah it's like
skipping ahead I guess one thing that I
find really fascinating about this
trailer is yeah I don't know much about
the history this may or may not be
borrowing from for the central storyline
of the central mystery with these
racially motivated murders or what seems
like racially motivated murders I feel
like that's an interesting I'm excited
and and fascinated to see how they're
gonna handle that side of things because
they always delve into the psychology of
these people and and they talk to the
people who do these things and to kind
of see what motivates that level of
racial based hatred could be an
interesting territory to explore
nowadays that you know we're butting up
against some really nasty racism again
in culture I feel like if handled
properly this could be something
interesting and sort of cultural for the
show to explore and then we got our two
white heroes definitely we're gonna save
everybody make it all better the only
thing that can stop a bad guy with a gun
is a good white and another thing that
feels different about this specific
season based off just about the trailer
has given us in the first season that I
remember they went around like a lot of
it was a road tripping this one seems
like it's gonna primarily take place in
this one town and yeah it seems like
their operation is now set it's really
yeah they're gonna be in one location
which feels a little more interesting to
me something a little bit more like
zodiac or a GaN girl which takes place
in just one town and you're kind of
watching the way the town is reacting
you've got this town shake of paranoia
yeah and they were saying that thing
about hold said something that really
upset ya and I'm like what the hell that
whole do now I remember like that actor
was being interviewed and it was saying
how it was interesting to play
characters not that likable I'm like
characters not like really like
very charming when you when you're a
protagonist amongst a bunch of serial
killers it's not hard to believe and I
think that there is something to be
concerned about in these sort of
fanaticism over serial killers and
especially when we have a time like this
work somebody like Charles Manson is
popping up and a lot of popular
entertainment and I think this show
highlights in a fascinating way yeah
like is at the core about who are the
humans and what are the minds like that
make these things happen that's what I
always look forward to the most here so
I hope that they can avoid I mean
there's always gonna be controversy but
you know finatus izing those elements
making good on the psychological like
let's explore let's you know sure sure
sure sure sure
but then I do want my you know serial
killer cinematic universe to be explored
oh yeah I want graphic reading all the
murders on Death Punch of killer Cammy
hopefully Wombles we want you to treat
it with respect
but then also jam-pack it with real-life
serial Brian house respect it anyway
guys are you excited for mine hunter
season - I bet you are
everyone's hyped you guys can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell make sure to check us
out on our patreon page and it's gonna
page today shadow - a man named David
Waterhouse welcome back David
Waterhouse my friend last time we talked
you were telling me about some real
difficult times you've been going
through I just want to tell you right or
sincerely that you are a major
inspiration to me I don't want to go
into any details it's very private the
fact that you've been able to still keep
your head above ground during all this
[ __ ] is mind blowing in it of itself I
don't know anyone who has had to deal
with the kind of specific struggles
you've had to deal with physically and
emotionally you are one of my heroes
that being instead if things get too
tough try killing people out just try
just try it yeah that's right
you know and have fun with it you know
come up with like a calling card style
we've never killed I want to make that
clear not yet but I think maybe you
ought to give it a shot and if you don't
blame us no but if people end up liking
you know where to give credit I mean you
know you could shout us out in one of
you
murders or something like leave one of
our videos playing at the scene or
something like that or like you know
carve real rejects logos get us
attention into someone you know yes
severed limbs it's good to have you back
Dave